احنا في الكاب 20 ومن احد الملفات اللي
بيتم التحدث عنها وهو الامن المائي يعني
في يوم للتمويل في يوم للامن المائي في
يوم لكل حاجه طيب لحد النهارده انا خلينا
نتحدث مبدئيا عن كابتن
وده مش مؤتمر لمصر حضرتك بتمثل مصر ايه
اللي حضرتك شايف
الحقيقه مبدئيا كده لما بنتكلم على
الكعب انا الحياه فخور جدا باللي مصر
عاملاه تنظيم على اعلى مستوى سالت كل
اصدقائي اللي انا اعرفهم من زمان اللي انا
اعرف ان هم مش هيخبوا علي لو عندهم نقد
الحقيقه بيقولوا لنا القبض ده فارق كثير
عن القبس اللي قبل كده همم في عدد الحضور
في طريقه التنظيم همم في الدخول في الخروج
فانا فخور جدا بالتنظيم والكلام الناس
بالنسبه للمحتوى لما نتكلم على المحتوى
الحياه بالنسبه لنا احنا وزاره الموارد
المائيه والري همم احنا هدفنا من القبضه
واضح جدا احنا عايزين البوزيشن الميه في
قلب العمل المناخ للاسف في القبس اللي قبل
كده واكيد حضرتك عارفه ان المياه ما كانتش
بتلعب دور خالص كل الكلام على ثاني اكسيد
الكربون والدواء الصناعي والنعزلها
ونقللها ولكن الحقيقه ما كانش في كلام عن
الميه احنا بنقول ده الكوب بتاع افريقيا
وده الكوب بتاع الميه ومش كلام ولا وعود
تنفيذ هو ده الشعار اللي احنا ماشيين به
يمكن كل السيشنز اللي انا حضرتها عرضت
مبادره مصر هي مبادره همم خارجه من مصر
ولكنها مبادره بلوبل همم بتتكلم على اسمها
اوير اكشن
اقل القارات مسؤوليه ولكن الاكثر تضررا
لازم العالم تقوم بدورها كفانا كلام
عايزين تنفيذ المبادره دي مش كلام
المبادره دي فيها مشروعات على ارض الواقع
هتتنفذ وتتحقق في افريقيا وهو ده الحقيقه
همم سببه وجوده هنا هو ال- ال- وضع المياه
في قلب العمل المناخي بالتنفيذ على الارض
طيب بت همم مخرجات كثير من مؤتمرات سابقه
ولكن فجوه التمويل بتؤثر بصوره كبيره جدا
100 مليار اللي كانوا في كوبنهاجن حتى ما
اتدفعوش همم بالنسبه للامن المائي يعني هل
توجد اليات معينه ممكن تضمن تنفيذ اي ما
يتم الاتفاق حوله في هذه الظروف همم هو
الحقيقه في كذا ثقه في شق قامت به الحكومه
المصريه قبل ووقعنا امبارح همم عدد كبير
من ال- همم من التعاقدات او في في جزء
منهم تعاقدات في جزء منهم ام ويوسفيه بس
حقيقه يعني في مشروعات تانجول بارقام
كبيره قوي يمكن ما هي خاص وزاره الموارد
المائيه والري من التوقعات ال- ال-
التوقعات اللي تمت امبارح في حضور همم
دوله رئيس الوزراء وطبعا مجهود كبير من
وزاره التعاون الدولي همم كانت مع التعاون
مع وزاره الزراعه ومع الايفاد وفي حاجات
ثانيه في المستقبل ان شاء الله في الايام
اللي جايه ففي حاجات تم توقيعها بالفعل
مشروعات على ارض الواقع معنيه
ال- ااا ال- التطوير الري وتطوير المنظومه
الري في مصر فده يهمني جدا الموضوع ده همم
وقعت برده اول امبارح مع اسبانيا همم برده
لنفس الموضوع همم تعاقد جديد مع اسبانيا
بس ده تعاقد فعلي همم
بمنحه
لتطوير الري في مصر وان شاء الله في
الايام اللي جايه في توقعات ثانيه بس انا
عايزين اكثر من كده عايزين المبادره دي
يكون لها ارقام كبيره همم تمويل همم
وليست قروض تتم لتطوير منظومه المياه في
مصر وفي افريقيا بشكل عام
يعني تطوير هذه المنظومه استخدام المياه
المحلات والتطين الترع
ولكن مازلنا بنعتمد على 90% كما اعتقد من
يعني طب قولي حضرتك بالنسبه لتبطين الترعه
لان كان في لغات كبير حول ان هذا التطين
لا يفيد وان بيحصل بخر بالنسبه لتبطين
الترعه تحديدا
كيف تراها وهل سيتم استكمال هذا هذه يعني
الخطوات التي بدات فيها الوزاره
المشروع اسمه تاهيل الترع وليس تبطين
الترع وهنا الفرق برده علشان المشاهد يبقى
عارف تاهيل الترع هو احياء الترعه مره
اخرى وتجديد شبابها عشان تقوم بالوظيفه
الاساسيه ايه الوظيفه الاساسيه اللي بترعى
ان هي توصل الميه للفلاح في الوقت المناسب
بالكميه الكافيه همم بالجوده ال- ال-
المعقوله دي الثلاث حاجات لو الترعه
بتقدمها يبقى انا مش لازم ابطنها لو
الترعه ما بتقدمهاش يبقى انا لازم اشوف
ايه المشكله هل المشكله في طابتين او غير
التبطين همم انا مش عايز الناس وهو متخيله
ان احنا نبطن طلع مصر كلها وبالتالي همم
المشروع ده كان له نتائج ايجابيه على
الارض طبعا كان له نتائج ايجابيه انا نزلت
ولفيت وسالت الفلاحين في فلاحين ما كانش
بيوصل لها ميه من عشرات السنين في اراضي
بور ابتدت ترجع تتزرع ثاني فلاحين سعيده
جدا بالمشروع ده فالمشروع حقق اهداف له
طيب طريقه استكمال المشروع ان احنا بنعمل
متر ميرفيو او ريفيو مرحله مراجعه مرحله
للمشروع وهو مستمر ما فيش وقت للمشروع في
استمرار للمشروع ولكن بتطوير اللي حصل قبل
كده بنطوره اكثر اي مشروع ضخم في همم
بالحجم ده لازم يتم مراجعته من وقت للثاني
بنشوف ايه الخبرات اللي استفدناها لان
طبعا كنا بنبطن همم وبن اهل اطوال كبيره
جدا في وقت ضيق وبالتالي بنحاول نشوف ايه
الحاجات اللي ممكن نحسنها وبنحسناها
وعملنا حاجه اسمها دليل او جيد لاين همم
يطور كل اللي بيستفيد من كل اللي حصل في
الماضي وعلشان يكمل في المستقبل مشروع
مكمل
عندما تقوم بعرض لمشكله المياه في مصر
واعتماد مصر على مياه النيل بنسبه 90%
وانتم بتعرضوها الان امام العالم وليس فقط
الدول الافريقيه كيف يتم استقبال هذا لان
كان في مفاهيم مغلوطه ان مصر بتهدر المياه
ان ان كيف استقبلت الدول كلها المشاركه
هذه المبادره وهل الان الجميع
يعني همم النيل بالنسبه لمصر ايه حضرتك
اعتماد مصر على مياه النيل 97% من المياه
الموارد المائيه الجديده لمصر همم هو على
نهر النيل الامطار حاجه لا تذكر والمياه
الجوفيه غير متجدده معنى كده ان احنا كمان
المياه الجوفيه بالنسبه لنا رقم محصور جدا
وبالتالي همم لما يكون اعتماد الدوله
المصريه 97% على مياه نهر النيل يبقى نهر
النيل ده له قيمه كبيره عندنا ومش بس من
دلوقت من ايام الفراعنه اللي بيقول ان
احنا بنهدر المياه يقول لي اجابه سؤال
بسيط جدا لما اتبنى السد العالي كان تعداد
ده فوق ال 20 من مليون مواطن وكانت الميه
اللي بناخدها 55.5 مليار النهارده مازالت
هي نفس المايه 55.5 مليار واحنا بقينا 104
مليون اللي بيقول بنقدر يقول لي ازاي احنا
عايشين عايشين بحسن اداره المياه عايشين
بكفاءه مهندسين مصريين عايشين باستثمارات
الدوله المصريه
وابداع في طريقه اداره الميه واعاده
استخدامها منظومه المصريه لتوزيع المياه
والريال للناس شايفاها دي منظومه في منتهى
الحكمه ومنتهى القدره ان هي بتوقيت
استخدام كل نقطه ميه اكثر من ميه فالحقيقه
الانتقاد ده اي مهند الصغير في الجامعه
يعرف يقدر يفهم قد ايه كفاءه منظومه الميه
في مصر يعني الامن المصري المائي طبعا
الدوله المصريه بتحفظه وبتستمر فيه علشان
نواجه الزياده السكانيه وهمم كل مؤسسات
الدوله عارفه همم اهميه همم المياه لمصر
واهميه نهر النيل لمصر وانا عايز اطمن
الناس ان الدوله المصريه فعلا موضوع ملف
الميه هو اولويه اولى في الدوله المصريه